まして で いわゆる心の育ち方なんですね
今日はどうやって心を調伏しますかと
いわゆるわかりやすく言えば
心を育てて育て 大事にありがたく
我が子のように守るんじゃなくて
仏教でいうのはそんなもんも捨ててしまえと
人間にとっては心っていうのは大変大事なものなんですけど
この前も申し上げたと思いますけど
すべて仏教ではこの神様とか主として見ているのは心なんですね
心っていうのはものすごい大きなもので
もうそれによってすべては変化しているんだと
心のまあわがまま次第なんですね
存在というそのものが
それはどんな次元でも説明できますよ
我々が知っている普通の常識の科学的な知識で見ると
人間が心で考えて世の中いろいろな変化しているんです
そこで 2つの変化がありまして
我々は意識でいかに楽になるかという科学的な進歩というか
発展というか そういう変化の過程があるんですね
それに人間が一生懸命考えて苦労して
どうすれば幸福になるかとという方向へ行ってるんですね
そこで同時に我々は自分を破壊していくんですね
科学は進歩していて 新しい新しいもの
ものすごい便利なもの
毎日毎日出てきて もう便利なもの
あまりにもありすぎて
すごい不便になっている状態なんですけど
そこまで便利なものを作って作っていきますが
ある反面で我々自分の生き方
存在そのものをすごい危機に
もう脱しているんですね
それは誰でも知識人という方々は知っていることで
じゃあそこで問題が生まれる
なんで心が 人間の心がそんなに豊かになりたくて
幸福になりたくて 自然を変化しながら
自然を改善しながら成長していくならば
なんで自然そのものは危機になってるんですかと
いわゆるそういう状態になってるんですか？なんで我々の命さえ今大変危険な状態になってるんですかと
それは心ですか 何ですかと
やっぱりそれも心なんですね
今 自然の破壊の問題にしたっても
我々の心の精神的な問題にしたっても
それから生まれつき子供たちがいろんな病気を持って生まれてくる
このうつ病なんかは当たり前のことで
もう社会に適応できなくて
もう自信がなくて隠れたがるのは
もうそんなものはもう当たり前で
別に不思議でもなんでもない状態になってるんですね
それからアトピー アトピーですか
そういうアレルギーみたいないろんなものが出て
卵を食べられないし パン食べない食べられない
あだこだとかでいろんな問題が出てきて
じゃあそれは何ですかというと
そこも心の働きで 心はそういうふうにしているんです
どういうことかというと
この自然を科学的に自然を改善しようと思うところで
ものすごく欲が働いてるんですね
金儲けようと偉くなろうと
そういう科学者でも 本当に純粋に新しいものを作って
ああ これ楽しいや みんな役に立ったならば
これいいんじゃないかとかね
面白いやという このゲーム感覚で楽しくやるものじゃないんです
ものすごい舌を噛んで
歯を噛んで もう汗もう脂汗流しながら
もう研究して研究して
もういろんなものを作ったりする
それはもうどうやってうまく売られていっぱいお金が入るかということは
そこに確実にあるんですね
それはないわけないんですね
経済という概念を捨てちゃったら
現代科学発展というのは全部そのままストップするんだから
科学のための科学は全くないし
面白いんだからという科学はもう世の中でないし
知らないものは知ってやろうという科学ももうないんです
儲かるかないかということになっていて
それでそれは欲であって
その場合はやっぱり相手を倒さなくちゃいけないという暗いエネルギーも一緒に行動しているんですね
でも 人間の悪いところは
自分がものすごい醜い暗いエネルギーで頑張ってるっていうことは無視すること
気づいてないこと それで何を発見しても
何を発明したっても そこに 50% 落とし穴が確実にあるんです
石油を発見して それで車を発展して
まあ楽に生きるの生きてるんだけど
そこですごい自然破壊というか
人間を堕落する落とし穴が確実にある
コンピューターの時代でも
今 今流行っている情報化の社会の時代にしても
必ずもそこにすごい危険があるんです
みんないいところだけ見る
例えば今のまあもうネットワークの時代ですか
もう誰でも自分のホームページなんか作ったりして
世界中どこでもまあまあコンタクトできるんだと
ですからもうある人々言うんですね
もうちょっと時間経つと政府なんかはもう何の関係もなくなっちゃうんだと
みんな個人個人で偉くなっちゃって
もう誰でももう活動したり
コミュニケーション取ったり
まあそういうふうな世界になってくるんだと
もう偉そうに威張って言うんだけど
そこにもすごい大変 何もコントロールできない
人間の我がままを好き放題勝手に言っちゃうと
もう何もコントロールできない
政府は成り立たない 法律は成り立たないとか
いわゆる何て言いますか
アナーキーという英語で言うんだけど
そういうふうな時代も現れる恐れが確実にそこにあるんですね
例えばもう道徳は消えてしまうわ
子供たちにもう知ってほしくないものは勝手に自分で知るんだから
知るのはいい 自由だけど
それによって心が汚せるのは何もできないでしょうに
例えば大人の世界であるいろんなものでも
僕なんかはものすごい
あのもうなんて言いますか
このもうすごい あの いい加減なことを考えてるんだから
別に子供はもう何したってもいいんじゃないかと思ってますけど
何したってもいいんですが
その知ってるものによって心が大変なダメージを受けるとか
それはコントロールできない
私にしたっても 例えば子供がまあもう酒でも麻薬でも使ってふざけて
いけないことをやったりみたりしたら
やりたいからどうぞやってくださいと僕でも言うんです
続けたければ やりたければ
でも子供に私でもコントロールできないのは
そういうことをやっちゃって
ここで心はもう全くもう壊れてしまっちゃって
汚れてしまっちゃって
自分を見失って 人生はもう全く無茶苦茶になっちゃうということは
もうどうしようもないんですね
その場合は ですから どこかでやっぱりそんなことは見ない方がいいよと
聞かない方がいいよという
保守的な もうちょっとした鍵も
もうストップマークもしておかなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで我々持っている知識の知識レベルで見ても
心がこの世界を変化して持っていくんですね
じゃあ現代科学文明の神様は誰ですかというと
人間の知識であって心なんですね
それで現代のこの破壊の神様は誰ですか？というと
それまた同じく人間の心であってと
その思想をもっともっと広げて
限りなく広げてみたっても同じことで
すべてのものは我々は心によって支配されていると仏教で言う
心というのは命であって
生きているというエネルギーであって
そういうふうに見ると
動物でもどんな生命でも何か違う
物質と違う何かエネルギーは持っていて
それで変化しているんだろう
ですから 無生物も我々生きている社会は変化していく
変化しているんですよ
動物も 私たち生きているこの地球はありとあらゆる変化をしているんですね
ですから 私たちだけ神様ではないんです
自分の内にいるゴキブリも神様なんですね
神様という言葉を使いたければ
その教えはヒンドゥー教では全てのものは神であると
もうとても簡単に言ってしまっちゃうんですね
仏教では全てのものは心によって支配されていると
そういう神という言葉はちょっと入れ替えて
その代わりに心というもっと具体的なものを言葉を使っているんですね
ですから 神様に対してすごい愛情を持ってる方々
私は神を馬鹿にするとすごい気持ちがちょっと痛いという気持ちがあるような感じがありましたけど
別にあまり気にしなくたっていいんです
神でもいいし 心でもいいし
神というと なんで私はそんなに文句を言いますかというと
神というと なんか我々と離れていて
何か超越した存在で 我々の支配者で
もう彼が好き勝手に我々を管理しているんだというふうな
このバイフリケーという
この何と言いますか  2つに分けて考えるのは良くないんだと
そんな親分がいるならばとんでもない親分だと
なぜならば こんな苦しみの世界を作っちゃって
弱肉強食の世界を作っちゃって
人間にはどうしようもない
納得いかない生き方ですから
それはもうありえないんだと
ですから もう神でもいいし
心でもいいし 我々はこの持っている実際の心なんですね
それはよく感じているもので
よく知っているもので
心はさえ抜けてしまえば
ここにあるのは何もできない
ただの物体だけなんですね
体として 人が死んじゃったら
そこに残るのはただの物体だけ
それは燃やしても埋葬してしまっても
海に捨てたってもどうでもいいことで
人間の頭悪いんだから
遺体の上にまた死にかけようと思ったり
葬式やるわ 骨を持ってきていろいろなことをやる
まあまあ いろいろうるさいんだけどね
お墓作ってみんなに迷惑かけるわ
まあそれは人間のまあ勝手ですけど
結局どうでもいいことなの
人死んじゃったら その物体はね
燃やして灰にする するか
その灰を持ってきて 植木鉢に入れてなんかね
肥料に使うか どっちでも構いませんよ
それはもうそこに心がないんだから
心という認識機能はそこにないんだから
それは普通の物質と同じであって
文化的にはこんな失礼なこと言われたらどうだと思うかもしれませんだけど
僕から見ても骨は骨を持ってきて
おじいちゃん ああだこうだとかしゃべるの
あれはものすごく理解できないんですね
まあなんか骨と思ってきて
それをお位牌の前でおじいちゃんただいま帰りましたとか
もう何言ってるんですかと
生きてる時はおじいちゃんがああだこうだと言うのはわかりますけど
心がそこにあるんだから
生きてる間は散々迷惑かけちゃって
言うこと聞かないし もうもう嫌だと思っちゃうし
早く死んでくれないかと思ったりもするし
死んだところで骨の前でもまた自分と死に死んでしまうぐらい
ものすごい もうなんて言いますか
執着を持って まあそういうのはまあ文化ですから
まあ僕はいろんなことを無茶苦茶言ったってもね
それはまあ別な話で まあ合理的に言うならば
あまり意味がないというぐらいのことで
その話はちょっと置いておいて
心だけ抜けてしまえば
そこにあるのは物体だけであって
ですから我々は心というどういうものかとちゃんと知ってるんです
結局は そこで その心によって我々は病気にもなるし
元気にもなるし ゆっくり年取るし
早く年取るし 寿命はずっと生活して死んじゃうし
早死になっちゃうし それ全部心の仕業なんですね
例えば心は我が儘でいい加減で好き勝手だったら早く死んでしまっちゃうでしょうに
心は大人しくして法則に従って行動するならば
まあ長生きできるし 心は暗くなっちゃったらもう体も病気になっちゃうし
家族も不幸になっちゃうし
社会もすごいダメージを受けちゃうし
すごい明るい 優しい 簡単な軽い心で生きているならば
もうみんな幸福で幸福で楽しく生きていられるし
全部心次第なんですね
ですから お釈迦様はやっぱり心は主であって
心に支配されてこの世の中は動いているんだという
チッテーヌ ニエティー ローコ チッテーヌ パリカッセティ チッタッサ エカ ダンマッサ サッベーワ サマン アブという言葉なんですけど
そこで仰っているんですね
全ての人々はサッベーワ サマンのア
全ての人々は心に支配されて抑えられているんだと
ですから 他の宗教で神という概念で扱っているものを
我々の仏教では心という言葉で見てるだけで
なんで心ということを使ってますかというと
それは平等である どんな生命にもあることであって
誰が選ばれた人間はいません
宗教にすると なんかすごい不公平
不公平なんですね たとえヒンドゥー教の人であっても
神の口から現れたのはブラフマン人であって
ですからもうすごい偉いんですね
バラモンカーストの人は神の口から生まれたんだと
ブラームナノス テ ムカマ アシという風なヴェーダの言葉で言ってるんですね
口から生まれたんだと
それから この国を治めている王様たちやら
そういう人々はこちらから
この手の上の方 何て言いますか
え？腕ですね 腕から生まれたんだと
もう神はそう作っちゃったんだから
もうどうしようもないと
そこで太ももの方から一般の人々を作ったんだと
足の裏からこの不可触民族という
このシュードラという人々は作ったんだと
だから文句言わないで
自分のカーストに決めたものはやりなさいと言って
この人 人種差別ですか
それを堂々と神の言葉を借りても
人をいじめること 人種差別すること
人が成長することにも邪魔しているんですね
そんなものは認められませんね
常識で言えば それでお釈迦様はいくらバラモン人であろうとも
泥棒するやつらはもう泥棒であってバラモンじゃないんだと
嘘をつく人は嘘つきであって
何のバラモンですかと
すごいキツい言葉で批判するんですね
そこで心清らかな人はワイシャであろうが
シュードラであろうが
バラモンであろうか その人こそが優れているんだと
心清らかにすることは
この不可触不可触民族だと言っているシュードラの人々にもできるんだから
そこでお釈迦様は出家する場合はカーストは聞かない
見るのは心清らかにしたいんですかという真面目かといい加減か
それだけなんですね 本当に本気になって自分の心を磨きたいと思うならば
どうぞ来てくださいと
そこで出家したものにはカーストはなし
その中でどんなカースト低い低い
一番下の不可触民族だと思う人でも
もし修行して悟ったならば
みんなその人に頭を下げて
地面に額をつけて礼をする
素晴らしい人間だと 尊い人だと
そういうふうに言えば
もう革命的で言えば革命的な教えなんですけど
結局すべては平等であるということはとことん力強く言っただけではないんです
実行してみせたんです
お釈迦様は一番高いカーストに生まれたんだけど
自分がどんな人の家にも何のことなく行く
そこで不可触の民族の人々だけものを乞うて食べるんです
お釈迦様は自分の食事はそのようにもらいましょうと決めたんです
お釈迦様は自分のお父様に
私にはちゃんと 1 日 1食ぐらい送ってくれと言っちゃったらちゃんと送ってくれますよ
王子でしたから そこで他の国々の王様たちも大変友達でしたから
何の問題もなかったんですし
でもそんなことはなし
自分で家ごとに行って托鉢をする
そこでもらうご飯を誰からあげてもらっても関係なく
どんなカーストの人からもらっても関係なくそれを食べて
だから自分でもう実行したんですね
そこでお釈迦様に何かちょっとカーストに対して何か言ったら
すぐもうそれにはきつい言葉言葉で批判する
心清らかなことを教えてくださいと言ったら
すごい優しい言葉で教えてあげる
例えば髪の毛剃ることも大変不名誉なことなんですね
インドでは 特にバラモン人は髪の毛は剃らなかったんです
それでたまにお釈迦様にこんなハゲ頭というふうに
バラモン人が悪口を言うんですね
言ったらお釈迦様はもうハゲ頭っていうのは誰ですか？知ってるんですか？と言って
心が汚れて怒りやら嫉妬やら人をけなしたりする心をかすかにも育てようと思わない人こそ不可触民族であって
その人はもうそういう批判するべき人であると
着ているものはどうであろうか
生まれはどうであろうか
心は清らかな汚れていない貪瞋痴はない人こそ聖者であって
素晴らしい人ですよと
もうとことん言っちゃうんですね
そこでヒンドゥー教でこの神様がカーストを作ったというんだから
お釈迦様こう聞くんですね
動物を見たら動物は違いますよと
差があるんだと 例えば鳥はどうやって子供を作るかというと
卵を産んで子供を作ると
じゃあ犬猫はどうやってというと
やっぱり哺乳類だから子供を産んで育てる
与えてるんだと 人間 私は人間見る限りはブラフマで
ブラフマの人であろうが
クシャトリヤであろうが
一般人であろうが 不可触民族であろうが
どんな女もどんな男も同じじゃないんですかと
妊娠することもお互いに男女が一緒になるやり方にしたっても
子供育てることにしたっても
おっぱいあげることみんな同じではないかと
だから人類は一緒でしょうと
そういう風にきつく言って
だから でも人間の中には差があるんだと
人のものを取るやつは泥棒であると
嘘を言うもの人は嘘つきであると
怒りやら嫉妬やら 汚れてる心を持ってる人は汚れた人間であると
そういう差があるんだと
心の差において人間の差があるんだと
でも心と言えば誰にでも育てられますから
もう泥棒したっても その人にはそれはやめられるし
嘘を言う人には嘘を言うことはやめられるし
嫉妬で嫉妬ばっかしでもう汚い心を持ってる人には
それ嫉妬をやめて明るい人間になることはいくらでもできるし
ですから 神という言葉は全然使わない
その代わりに全く自然法則論という
あの背景の中で この何と言いますか
バックグラウンドの中で心というものの概念を使ってるんですね
そこで釈尊は徐々にどのように我々は心を育てますかと
心にはネガティブ いわゆる暗い働きがありますと
明るいポジティブ働きがありますと
そこで暗い働きが働いちゃったら
徐々に徐々に人間生命というのは進化することではなく
退化していっちゃうんだと
明るい働きが心に働いちゃったら
人間では誰であろうが生命は進歩していきますよと
その目で現代科学を見ると
どんな心かというと 五分五分というか
もう暗いエネルギーも明るいエネルギーも両方混ぜて心が働いてるんですね
ですから 我々は現代社会人が豊かといえば
ある面で見れば豊かであって
大変楽であるし ある面で見れば大変不幸であるし
それは心のエネルギーはもう暗くもあって
白くもあって もうもうごちゃ混ぜなんですね
だから結果もごちゃ混ぜなんですね
で 昨日も思い浮かんだんだけど
いろんな精神的な ちょっといろんなトラブルある人々はいろいろいるんだと
みんななんかすごく自信がないんだという話が出てきて
で まあ若者っていうのは何か聞いたらすぐそこにもうもう吸い込まれちゃうんだと
自分で何も決断できないんだと
ちょっとしたことで自信を失っちゃうんだと
すぐうつ病になっちゃうんだとか
何かに頼りたがっちゃうんだと
すがりたがっちゃうんだとかね
で もうなんでしょうかとか
どうこうとか言われると
僕は考えたの一つは もうもしかするとそれは現代科学文明の産物かもしれません
科学的に証明できないんだけど
我々はもう空気はもうすでに徹底的にありとあらゆる電波で汚染されてるんですね
電波っていうのはきついもので
もう物質 細胞を通って
もう細胞の核を通って何のことなくもう逃げていくは
そこで止まって止まるか
電波なんか体に止まっちゃったらアンテナみたいに
それエネルギーでしょうに
物質でしょうに 電波も
知らないうちに体の構成が変わっちゃうんですね
DNA は見たところで変わらないかもしれませんよ
でも仏教では地水火風という素粒子のレベルで物質を見ているんだから
素粒子のレベルで変わってるんだから
そうすると精神的な病気やら神経のおかしいところやら
脳細胞がおかしく行動するとかね
うつ病とか まあそんなものはもういくらかはあるだろうという風に考えられる
それは科学的に証明するためには
あと 20年ぐらいはかかりますよ
あまりも電波 電波使ったり
汚染されちゃって されたって
もう で それでもうたくさんデータが出たところで
やっと科学的に証明できたということで
その時はもう遅いですからね
ですから 我々の心っていうのは
そういう暗いエネルギーもいいエネルギーも両方混ぜて行動するんだから
現代的に我々得られるものについて
いつでもいい部分も悪い部分もいつでもついてるんです
もしそこら辺で我々は頑張って
まあ欲は捨てましょうと
単なる経済的に自分だけまあ力強い国になるためではなくて
他の国をに競争して抑えて
他の国を攻めるために活動するんじゃなくて
この地球上のすべての生命はいかに幸福に生きてられますかと
いかに楽しく生きていられますかと
そういう方向で我々は科学発明を方向転換すればどうですかと
考えれば より違う世界が確実に生まれてくるはずなんです
今の作ってるものっていうのは
もうどうでもいいことで
どっち買ったってもいいことで
同じものはみんな作っちゃうんですね
まあコンピューターにしたっても
種類のは大きさあるわあるあるわ
どっち買うかみんな困ったりするわ
何を買ったっても全然もうほとんど役に立たない
何か変なところあったりして
単なる私も売ってやる
私も売ってやるということだけなんですね
人間に役に立つっていうことを考えてない
結局は 何が役に立ってるよという風に言うだけで
そうでなきゃ買ってくれませんから
それでもじゃあなくて
誰か一人の会社が人間のみんなに必要なものをコンピューター作ってあげますよって言ったら
そこで競争もないし みんな文句もないでそれ買っちゃうし
それにバカ高いお金値段つけなくてもいいし
まあそういう風に競争ない世界も仏教では考えられるし
仏教は競争には反対ですからね
競争するんじゃなくて
共存することは大事であって
共存することは競争するよりは難しいチャレンジなんです
だから競争なきゃ面白くないんだと
社会は進歩しないよというのは嘘なんです
競争は怒りでやっているんであって
いくらか進歩はあるんだけど
もうそこでダメになっちゃうんですね
競争したんだからやられちゃいますから
それより難しいのは共存なんです
ですから共存しようと思っちゃうと
今の知恵では足りません
今の知識は全然当てにならない
ものすごい知識と ものすごい幅広い次元違う知恵っていうものが必要になっちゃうんです
ですから 仏教はみんな現代人にも言ってるのは
競争を捨てて共存の概念でいけばどうですかと
今の考え方を全部覆し
覆しちゃって 今の経済的な概念
弱肉強食の概念をもう変えてしまっちゃって
共存的な概念にすればどうですかとか
それは大変なチャレンジなんです
ちょっと怖いんです やるのは
でも全然怖くないんです
やってみれば その瞬間からすごい抜群の幸福が得られるはずなんです
自分が戦わないんだと
その代わりにみんなの幸福
みんな幸福になる方向にするんだと思ったら
その瞬間から素晴らしく人生変わってしまうんです
そこはこの超越の道でもあるんです
今のやり方でもう何の意味もないんです
例えば仏教を聞いて いろんな新興宗教に入っちゃって
皆様何を願っているんですかというと
健康 もう家庭安全とか
そんなくだらないものばっかりなんですね
商売繁盛とか いわゆるいかに競争できるかということなんですね
いかに相手を殺すかということなんです
結局は これ 宗教というのは優しい心を教えるところだから
優しいことを教えるところに行って
私に相手を殺す方法を教えてくださいと
人を助けるのはあなたの仕事ではないかというような
ものすごい矛盾だらけなんですね
そこで商売繁盛を売っている宗教は
僕はインチキ宗教だと堂々と悪口を言うのは
ものすごい高い次元から言ってるんです
別にその宗教を批判してるわけじゃないんです
そのある特定のを 人は買いたがるものを売ってあげるということは宗教ではないんだと
なぜならば 人は買いたがっている品物は
この競争の社会で相手を倒すために必要な武器にしか何もないんです
それはもう家庭円満とか商売繁盛とか
もう長寿とか健康的な体とかいろいろごまかし言葉を取ってるだけで
この競争の社会でいかに生き延びるかと
ということしか考えてないんです
そこは宗教で はい わかりました
あなた買いたがってるものは売ってあげますよと売っちゃうと
インチキのインチキ宗教しか有用もないんです
僕にとっては しょうがないんだけど
本当は人の概念は否定してはいけないんです
批判してはいけないんです
いけないんだけど まあ一応高い次元から私はそう言うんです
で 正しいのは この売りたがってるものを買いたがってる者おるんじゃなくて
なぜそれ買いたがるんですかと
それ買ったところで あなたにそれで何か役に立つんですかと
買いたがる気持ちを何とかしてもうやめさせてもらって
それよりはあなたには必要なこういうものだよと
心の余裕だよと 心の豊かさだよと
心の優しさだよと どんな問題にでも揺れない
心作ることだよと そうするとちょっと人気が消えるかもしれません
でも それはそれこそ宗教の仕事なんです
ですから 僕はまた失言言いますけど
世の中に釈迦様の教えしか宗教はないんです
みんなこのコマーシャルパックで
もう買いたがるものを売ってるだけなんです
仏教の話を聞くと ちょっと耳が痛い
ちょっとだけのところじゃないんです
結構耳が痛い 耳が痛いというならば
きちんと話は合ってるということでもあるんです
だからものすごい次元違う教えなんです
残念ながら 他の宗教と何か同じや
何比べたりとか そういう次元では理解できない
ですから この競争の世界を乗り越えて共存の世界をつくる心が
一つの仏教のメッセージであって
我々には社会変化することはできませんだから
私たち個人個人でお釈迦様というのはある面では鋭いんです
社会は地球スケールで変わらないということをわかってるんだから
個人に話しかけてるんです
あなただけやってみて
あなた幸福になってみてくださいと
あなたは人をもう締め殺すことをやめちゃって
共存的な心 すごい大きな寛大な心作って
みんなを理解できる心作って
たとえ何があろうとも落ち着いている心を作ってみてください
あなたは幸福になりますよと
そういうふうに個人に話しかけている
それがお釈迦様の一つの方便なんです
単なる社会論を喋ったって誰も聞いてくれませんだから
納得はしますよ 個人に言ってないんだから
痛くもない この社会はもっとより豊かな社会にせなくちゃいけないんですよと
競争のことはやめて もう我々は共存の社会を作らなくちゃいけないと
はいはい わかりました
我々は大賛成でみんな手を挙げますよ
なぜならば 個人に何も言ってないんだから
でも誰も実行しない その場合は
社会論は 単なる説教だけ
ですから お釈迦様はそれを考えて
個人にあなたはと そこを大乗仏教で間違って
もう初期仏教っていうのは何といいますか
自分の悟りしか考えてないんだとと悪口言いますけど
あれはすごい的外れな悪口で
かえって私も悪口を言うんですね
大乗仏教 向こうに悪口言われてるんだから
言い返するんです なぜならば
あなた方は救った人は一人もいるんですかと
私たちはもうおっしゃる通りに
自分の悟りのために頑張ってるんだと
でも私たちは悟り開いて救ってあげた人々は数きれないほどがいるんだと
あなた方は救ってあげた人は一人もいるなら名前出してください
一人もいないんです ただ口で言うだけで
一切の衆生の救いのためにとかなんとかとか
だから私は悟りませんと
輪廻にいるんだと それは菩薩行で偉いんだと
聞き目はいいんですよ
言葉だけは この美しい言葉ほど恐ろしい言葉はないんです
これは聖書でもジェズス様もわかって知っていたんです
ジェズス様 僕は隠れブッダと隠れ仏教徒だと思ってるんだから
悪魔こそ耳障りのいい言葉を喋ってくれませんと
耳障りのいい言葉だったら
もう何の言葉も悪魔の言葉だと
聞きたくない耳が痛い言葉っていうのは本当にジェズスの言葉ですよと
というのは聖書にさえあるんだからね
そういうかっこいい言葉ばっかりして
そこでどう見たても自分さえ悟れないで
自分さえ輪廻の中でもうドロドロ泥沼の中にいて
人にあなた悟ってくださいと
それで相手が聞くでしょ
菩薩に なんで私は悟らなくちゃいけないんですかと
輪廻は苦しいんだから
それでなんであなたは悟らないんですかと
いえ 私は悟ったら人を救えませんだからと
そこであなたの教えの最高の目的は何ですかと
それは自分の悟りを置いておいて
人の悟りのために頑張ることやと
ですから あなたもそうしない
それはみんな じゃあ私も悟らないで人を救うために頑張る
私も悟らないで人を救うために頑張ります
誰一人も悟れませんよ
だから実際にあるのはそういう現状なんです
みんなガタガタ状態で
それであまりうまくいかないんだから
またいろんなみんな真面目に修行したりはする
結局 和尚は偉そうな大乗の話を言うんだけど
結局自分たちはどこかで隠れて瞑想しているんだから
実際にはもう個人で頑張るしかないんですよ
なんでそれごまかしますかと
たとえ親鸞聖人にしても
念仏唱えなさいと それであなたはもう極楽浄土に生まれ変われますよと
個人にまあもう極楽浄土という
まあもう何か概念を与えてあげて
そこでその個人には何か教えてるだけで
その分だけは宗教は生きてるんです
個人の役に立つ分だけ宗教は生きてるんです
ですから 大乗仏教もいくら批判されたっても
なんとか生きてるんです
この生きてる部分は我々と同じく個人個人のために何とかしてあげる分だけなんです
僕らの違うところは まあ正直だけなんですね
嘘は言わないだけのことです
偉そうな なんか偉いかっこつけて言葉使わない
やっぱりもう社会はもう変わりません
だから我々説法したっても
私はいくらもうこういう風に喋ったっても
誰も聞いてくれませんし
ですから 心を清らかにしたいという個人が
自分の心を清らかにして
自分が豊かになれば まあそれで結構じゃないんですかと
ということにもなるんです
そこで自分が豊かになったならば
私は心豊かになりましたよと
問題ないんだと そうすると悩んでる人々は
なんでこの人だけニコニコとこんなに問題あるのに
全然冷静な気持ちでよくいるもんですねとかね
よく問題すぐもうすぐさっさと手早く解決するもんですねとか
なんだかんでうまくいってるんではないかと
それで私にも教えてちょうだいと言ったところで
自分が実行して試した方法だから信頼できるんですね
嘘じゃないんだと インチキじゃないんだと
それで人の役に立つ ですから
僕らの初期仏教では リタ教と自己の何業ですかね
自利行っていうのは一緒なんです
区別しない 心清らかにすること
働きはみんなのためにでもあって
自分のためにでもあると
それは区別できないんだと
もし一人の方が修行するならば
その方は自分に関係あるありとあらゆる生命のために大変いいことをしているんです
皆様 考えてみてください
ものすごい怒りで怒りっぱなしで
わがままで自分が生きているんだと
そうするとみんなに迷惑でしょうに
みんなに迷惑でしょうに
会社に行ったら会社に迷惑
家に戻ったら家に迷惑
店に行ったら店の人々に迷惑
電車に乗ったら電車に乗ってる人々みんなに迷惑です
だからなんか歩く 歩くバイキンというかね
というふうに 存在でしょ
その歩くバイキンが自分の怒りやらわがままやら自分で直すと自分で頑張って直すといったらどうなりますかね
どこへ行ったっても みんなに幸福をもたらしてくれる歩く灯明になっちゃうでしょうに
どこにいてもみんなに光を与えてあげる
みんなの暗闇にいる人々には
もう自分が灯明でになって
それ仏教の言葉ですからね
あのなんて言いますか
ランタンですか このランポスト
そういう状態になって
自分の心は光り輝いている
そういう人は電車に乗ったって
他の人々には大変気持ち悪い
怒っている人が怒らなくなる
ただ 私は実際によく見ていたんだから
僕はもう僕のこと全然知らない
僕は日本ではもう完全にもう 20年いても 30年経っても
もう完全に外人で見られているんだから
まあそれはしょうがないんだけど
それなのにたまにこのおかしいことをしている人々やら
この不作為でみんなに迷惑かけてる子供たちさえ
たまに私は電車に乗ったところで
すぐおとなしくなっちゃうんです
なんのことなく あれは何ですかと
私の心はおとなしいんだから
僕は何も言いません 関係ないし
大きなお世話ですから
何か言ったらなんとなくおとなしくなっちゃって
それでも遊んではいるんだけど
それはみんなに迷惑をかけないように自分たちで遊ぶ
それを大人から見れば可愛くて可愛くて
子供たちは電車に乗ってものすごく明るく遊んでいるんだから
楽しいもんで それみんなに迷惑かけない
あの釣り 釣り 何て言いますか
あれにぶら下がってもうブランコにしたり
みんなに体にぶつかったり
それは迷惑でしょうに
この間も一つ見たんだけど
ある子供が 3人  4人ぐらいかな
すっごいうるさくて あまりもうるさくて
もうとんでもないガキのグループでしたけど
でも私は見た瞬間でちょっと心変わっちゃって
僕にあのヒンドーインドの言葉でナマステと言って
偉そうに礼をするんですね
でも私がそれちょっと反応したならば
あの子供たちは落ち着くんだけど
あんまりもうこのやり方がもうものすごく悪いんだから
僕は無視しちゃったんですね
そこで僕に無視されちゃったんだから
もうまた自分の世界に入って
またもうすごくみんなに迷惑をかけながら遊んでて
他の若い男の子にさんざん怒られたんですね
で 僕はまあ あなた方は悪いことしてるんだから
そういう結果になるぞという感じで
もうもう何も言えなかったんだけど
まあこちらも疲れています
子供のもうあっちこっちもう遊んであげるということをいつでもできるわけないんだから
とにかくまあ自分が落ち着いていると
他の人々は何も言わなくても幸福になるということで
我々には自分の心を育てるしか方法ないんです
私は自分 私たちは自分の子供たちは良くなって欲しければ
自分の家族が幸福になって欲しければ
会社は上手くなって欲しければ
日本国が幸福に豊かになって欲しければ
私個人にできることは
自分の分は自分が清らかな心を作ること
それで確実にその影響をみんなに与えると
そういう道は仏教でお釈迦様はきっちりとおっしゃってますから
もうだから信仰やらお祈りやらね
一応否定しますけど 例えばお祈りの場合でも
私は幸せでありますようにとか
生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますようにとか
願うのは素晴らしいことやと
それは清らかな波動だと
それに屁理屈持ってくるなと
生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますようにと思ったら
みんな幸せになりますかと
そんな簡単に幸せになるんだったら願ってあげたってもいいんだけどね
別にそんな簡単にはなりませんだけど
でも私たちは心からそういう神様
私を助けてちょうだいっていうのは醜い汚れている希望なんですね
そうじゃなくて 私は幸福でありますようにというのは汚れてないんです
当たり前のことだから
生命は幸福になりたい
病気になりたくない 苦しみには会いたくない
だけど私には苦しみ 悩みがなくなりますように
そういうふうに願うのは清らかなんです
そこで私の親しい人々も幸福でありますようにと
生きとし生けるものが幸福でありますようにと願う希望する
それでわがままな心はもう消えてしまう
もうわがままでは通用しなくなっちゃう
それで心はすごい大きくなって
光り光り輝く心になってしまうんです
そういう人はどこにいてもみんなの光
みんなに光を与えている
あの灯明になっちゃうんですね
で あの灯台になってしまっちゃうんです
それでみんな灯台になってしまったら
自然に光の世界ということ
いわゆる明るい世界というのが出てくる
まあそこそこまで話を一応一旦一部を停止
まあそこで終わりますけど
そのように釈尊は心を育てましょうということを言っている
そこで人の心を育てあげるではなくて
心には人も他もないんだから
まあ自分で心を育てるということで
最後に私は申し上げたのはこの浄道ということなんです
浄道というのは超越道で
我々の心はなぜ汚れるかという一番大事なところを考えちゃうと
心っていうのは自己中心で自我というものがありまして
それは self awareness と英語で言えるんですね
いわゆる自我意識なんですね
自分がここにいるという自我意識がありまして
で それをもっとわかりやすく言うならば
いつでも私たちの心の中で私
私という この思考の central point 中央点ですか
思考がこのこの私というセンターから回っているんですね
太陽みたいに 太陽を中心にして地球が回っているような感じで
我々のすべての思考が私という概念に基づいて
それは真ん中の中央点にして
思考はぐるぐる回っているんですね
どんな哲学であろうが
私がいる それはもうメインポイントで
それは出発点で そこからいろんなことを考えるんだ
そこはすごく気をつけてほしいポイントなんです
そこで仏教では あの これ我見という我見という仏教用語があります
それはただの漢字 2つなんですけど
我というのは私であって
見というのはいるというふうに
確実に徹底的に信じるということなんですね
私がいると で 世の中のすべての思想は我見中心なんです
で 哲学はどうですかね
私は何ですかと探すことでしょうに
インドの哲学は何ですか？私は何でしょうか
それを探すことなんです
ヨーロッパの哲学は全部そういうものなんです
もう科学はそこまで行ってないんだからね
道具を作る世界だからね
科学っていうのは 心理学は何ですかね
我見中心なんです そこで私がいると思っちゃうと
仏教は哲学を作るんじゃなくて
それを考える すべての哲学は我見中心ではないかと
じゃあパーリ語の言葉
パーリ語でこういう風に言うんです
それはお釈迦様の使ってる言葉なんですね
アッペディッティ アッタは我でディッティは見で
で もしお釈迦様も私は誰ですかという哲学で教えたならば
もう一つの宗教 もう一つの哲学になるだけなんです
別に大したことはないんです
それだったら 世の中 例えば車にしたら
もうトヨタの車もあって
あの 何でしたっけ 他の会社のも車あるんだとかね
日産の車あるんだと 別にどちらが唯一優れてるんですか？どっちでも同じことでしょうに
だから車買う人はデザイン見て
自分もポケットにあるお金の量を見て
じゃあこっちにしようかって決めるだけのことで
どんな車選んだっても同じことで
ホンダ買ったっても トヨタ買ったっても
日産買ったって ですから
この世の中の哲学にもう一つ哲学
一つ付け加えたわけじゃないんです
我見中心であったならば
このお釈迦様は考えたのはこの我見の恐ろしさなんです
我見の恐ろしさっていうのは
我見っていうのは私がいるというところから見ることだから
物事は自分の尺度で見るということになるんですね
そうすると事実はどうですかと
実際はどうですかという問題がそこに現れちゃうんですね
それで やっぱり人間には我見中心しか考えられませんだからそれしょうがないやと言えますかもしれませんだけど
我見中心になっちゃうと
私には私の意見がありまして
哲学がありまして 人生論があって
皆様にもそれぞれありまして
それでバラバラでしょうに
私は私は正しいと思っちゃうし
他のこと知りませんだから
皆様方は皆様正しいと思っちゃうし
そう どちらが正しいかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
ある人は酒飲んだっても構いませんと言っちゃうし
ある人は酒飲んだらダメやっていうし
どっちが正しいんですかね
わからないんだから ある人はタバコを吸ったってもいいんじゃないかと
気持ちいいんだからと
ある人はタバコ吸ってはいけませんと言ったりするし
全ては自分の意見であって
どちらが正しいかと言えません
食べ物にしても ある人はもう日本の和食はとてもいいんだと言っちゃうし
健康的だからと ある人はそうじゃないんだと
フランス料理の方がいいやと
中国料理がいいやと どちらが正しいんですかね
わからない どちらが正しいかと言えなくなっちゃうんです
そこで 何て言いますか
我見で見ているんだから
アッタディッティをもって物事を見ているんだから
全部自己中心な概念しか頭の中にない
それは頭の中にあると同時に確実に覚えておいてください
自分が自分の意見を持ってるということは
他人の意見と自分が違うということなんですね
ですから 自分の生き方
好き嫌いということ 自分の人生論
全ては他と違うんです
それで他人も自分が正しいと思っている
自分は自分が正しいと思っている
そうすると 我見がある人は自分を正当化しようと思っちゃう
思ってたと戦う 他人説教する
あなた間違ってるんだ
私の方が正しいんだと
説教したらどうなるかというと
その人はそれを嫌う その人に自分の生き方あるんだから
こちらのお母様方いらっしゃりますからね
小さいという子供は何も知らないとか
いろんなことをおっしゃったでしょうに
子供 ああありがたい よくわかりました
これからやりますと言ったことがありますか？ないでしょうに
全部反対されたんだから
たとえ 例えば食卓に食べ物をちゃんと用意したところで
子供は足を食卓に入れたりするでしょうね
たまに 遊んでるんだから足も柔らかいし
何のことなく足は食卓の上につけられるし
それでお母さんどうよ
足ぶって しっかりしなさいと
行儀が悪いやと言うのは
それでそれでも子供は
あ わかりました そんな行儀が悪いことはこれからしませんと
ありがとうございますと感謝したことは一度もあるんですかね
かえって怒られただけでしょうに
どういうことですかと
母にとってはいいことを教えているつもりですけど
子供のアッタディッティ
我見から見れば 自分の生き方に邪魔してるだけなんですね
ですから そこにたとえ親子の間でもうまくいかない
どこにも世の中で親子の間でうまくいかなかったら
社会の中でうまくいくわけないでしょうに
ですから こう喋っている私にしたってのも
いろんな小さい時は覚えてますから
やりたいことはいっぱいあって
それをやろうとしたらすぐもう怒られるんじゃないですか
だから母に怒られたら怖いんだからもうやらない
それでいい子いい子って言われるんだけど
別にいいこと言われることじゃなくて
ただ怖いんだからやってないだけなんです
それでやがて自分の生き方になってしまっちゃうだけ
その行儀のいい生き方は
それでも我々いまだにちょっと機会があったら
場があったらふざけてるんじゃないんですか
ちょっとなんか 例えば日本の方々っていうのは大変素晴らしい行儀のいい
平和的で素晴らしい方々なんですけど
もうちょっと前あったんですね
フィリピンやらタイやら旅行に行っちゃったら
世界一行儀の悪いもん
非文明的な野蛮人的な行動をするんだと嫌われちゃうんだと
あれは何ですかね 別に非文明的な人間であるわけでもなんでもないんです
ちょっと機会があったんですね
自分のやりたい放題やれる機会があったところで
もうやってしまっちゃうんですね
ただそれだけのことで
僕はタイ人 フィリピン人なんかね
それによって日本人批判するのはもう良くないと思ってるし
日本人がここで我々はすごい行儀が良くて
このアジア人とはすごい違いますよと思って威張ってるのもどっちでも良くないんだとと思ってるだけのことですけど
やっぱり私たちは行儀よくしなさいとここできつく言われてるんだからやってるだけであって
ちょっと時間がちょっと場があったらもうすぐ威張っちゃう
日本では別に誰でも別にお金持ちじゃないんだから
まあ質素で大人しくいますけど
タイやらそういう貧しい国々に行って自分の財布見たらものすごい大金持ってるんですね
それでまあ買いまくったり
ものすごい態度悪く振り回しちゃうんですよ
ですから あれは何ですかというと
やっぱり我々は機会さえあれば本音が出ると
わがままになるということなんです
別に悪くなったわけでもないんです
ですから 我々というのは自分の意見があります
我見があります その我見でわがまま放題で生きていたい
でも親からもうずっと始めて
それから学校の先生から
それから社会から それから会社からとか
いろんなことを言われて
もう抑えてるだけ そこにあるのはただ苦しみのみ
なぜかというと 母親は自分の我見が持っていて
それはこちらにぶん殴ることだから
子供はそれは嫌でしょうに
先生には先生の我見がありますから
それは生徒にぶん殴ってるだけのことだから
怖いだから大人しくするだけで
そこであまりいい気持ちはないし
会社は会社の我見がありまして
そのその人は自分の自我
相手にぶつかるだけであって
ああしなさいこうしなさいと
本人はそうはやりたくない
ですから 我々の生きるということは
何のことなく苦しみの塊になっているんです
いくら行儀のいい日本人であろうとも
行儀の悪い我々のアジア人であろうとも
同じことで 生きるということは大変苦しみの塊
それはなぜその苦しみがありますかというと
我見が持っているんだからなんです
自分の意見 自分という自我意識あるんだから
セルフアウェアネスだからなんです
そこでヨーロッパの哲学と違って
お釈迦様はこのセルフアウェアネスは自分がいるんだ
自分がここに存在しているんだと
自我意識こそ問題ではないかと
そこは苦しみの元ではないかと言って
その苦しみの元になる自我意識さえなければ
どこかでこの言葉に言い表せない
なんと素晴らしい自由が得られるんではないかということをもう考えたでしょうと思います
そこで 悟りの一番一番目に悟るということは
このアッタディッティという自我意識をなくなっちゃう
それなくなったら そこでもう心は超越しているんです
その瞬間で そこで全ての戦いは消えちゃう
そういう人には子供にいい行儀を教えてあげることはできるんです
私は教育の世界でいたものだから
私は何か相手に言う場合はこうするんですね
相手に判断させちゃうんです
自分で判断言わないで
規則は私は全然言わない
子供たちに規則を作られるんです
作らせるんです すごいずるいやり方なんですけど
例えば教室の中でものすごく大騒ぎするんだったら
全然静かにしなさいと言わないんです
どうそうと やってください
と 全く関係なく どうそうどうそうと言うんです
言って 話を聞きたい人はちゃんと前に来て聞いてください
それだけ それで大騒ぎしている連中も
何のことなく自分で静かになって
もう話を聞いてしまっちゃう
個人的に言う場合は 大騒ぎにしたらどうなるんですかと
相手に聞く それでどうなるんですか？それからどうなるんですか？と
相手に聞くだけ はい わかりましたと
わかりましたと返しちゃうと
本人がもうちゃんと自分で正しい道をもう決まってるんです
あるいはもうあんた なんで教室の中で大騒ぎしてたんだよ
そんなことやったらいけませんよとかね
もうしっかりしなさいと
おとなしくしなさいと
ちゃんと勉強しなさいと言ったら嫌われるだけ
言う必要ないんです 向こう聞くのはそんなにも学校で悪ガキやってね
大騒ぎしてみんなに嫌われて
それ楽しいですかと すごい面白い
それあれ本当に楽しいの？その一言葉で終わるんです
全部 すごい簡単なんです
でも必要なのは相手を責めないこと
自分の意見を押し付けないこと
それだけ ですから この自我意識というか
邪見さえなんとか捨てて捨てられれば
皆様はもう解脱の段階四つしかないんです
一段階目はもう達成しているんです
私は心の超越すると言っているのはそういうことなんです
心というこの汚れているやつを何とかして育てて
育ててそれを大事にしようということじゃないんです
心は大事にすればするほど
我見がすーっと引き吸ってくるんです
そんなもんは捨てた方がいいんです
でもなかなか捨てられないんだから
生きているんだから それで我見を破ってしまっちゃう
それで心は超越する そういうふうな道なんですね
そこでこの邪見に何で入ったんですかというと
世の中にあるすべての概念きつくこの暗記してください
そうでないと これはもう役に立たないんです
世の中にあるすべての概念
すべての思想 すべての哲学
たとえ文化であろうとも
たとえ歴史であろうとも
たとえ科学であろうとも関係なく
全てはその人 その人の立場から見た偏見であると
いわゆる立場から見た意見であって
真理には真理ではないんだと
ですから 別にそれでいいんじゃないかということも出てきますよ
音楽家は音楽こそ素晴らしいんだと
それこそ人生の哲学だと
だからたまに音楽家に聞くんですね
このテレビなんか見ると
あなたにとってはロック音楽は何ですかと
私にとってはそれは人生すべてですよって言うでしょうに
我々から見れば なんでバカな話やと思うかもしれませんだけど
あんなうるさい雑音作って
人のね この聴覚ですか
それも壊しちゃって 耳が耳も聞こえなくしちゃったりして
何が人生全てかと私は聞きたいんだけど
でも私は全然それはそうと
なぜならば その人の人生論はそれであって
その人に説教する必要ないんですよ
あんた間違ってますよと
そこで絵を描く人に聞けば
やっぱり絵は私の人生ですよと
すべてですよと 彫刻家に聞けば
彫刻は自分の人生ですべてですよと
政治家に聞えば 政治こそ自分の人生ですよ
すべてですよと だから僕らは仏教徒には勝手にやりなさい
どっちでもということなんです
で 仏教の立場から見れば
その一つもすべてじゃない
たった偏見だけ 偏っていうのは一つの側面しか見てない意見だけ
音楽は音楽は音楽家は音楽はすべてだったら
なんでご飯食いますかね？なんで人が作った服を着てるんですかね
すべてじゃないのはもう当たり前で
丸々知ってるのに でも音楽はすべてだと言っちゃうんです
その人もご飯は食べるわ
悩んでるとこはお母さんに電話してなんとかなんとかどうかもう自分のもう文句言うわ
人が作った服を着るわ
人のお世話になるわ いろんなことあるんじゃないんですかね
それで その上趣味もあるんです
僕らから見れば音楽自体趣味なのに
音楽家には別に趣味があるんです
ボートやらね まあ何でしたっけ
一番くだらなすぎません？ボールはあのゴルフとか
そういう趣味もあるんですね
ですから 人生すべてだったら
なんでゴルフやるんですかね？あれ自然破壊だからね
やめればいいでしょうに
ゴルフと釣りですか もうすごい
もう 本当にバカバカらしい
そういう 2つなんですよ
何も能力いりませんだからね
あれ出して待ってるんですね
引っかかるまで で まあまあそれはそれで
勝手にやってもいいんだ
僕に関係ないんだけどね
面白いだから言ってるだけで
まあとにかく本人人生全てじゃない
音楽家には音楽は 画家には絵を描くことは
政治家には政治は全てじゃない
お母さんに聞くもお母さんの人生なら
やっぱり子供育てることは私の人生やと
そうじゃないでしょ 本当は
他のこともやってるんだから
ですから 人間はもう自分の偏見を持っていて
別にそれは悪いとか間違ってると言ったっても何の意味もないんです
ただ 心心が大きくなってない
寛大になってない 物事が見えるようになってないんだから
そういうだけで そこで仏教ではそれは理解できる心を作ろうと
偏見は偏見だとちゃんと見られるようなこと
物事はありのままに見られる
でも自分では何も意見は持たない
自分の心には何もない
自分という自意識さえない
でも人が私は野球をやりたい
野球で生きていきたいというならば
それはちゃんと理解する
あ なるほど こういうこういうわけで
この人は人生は野球にかけたいんだと
今日そう頑張ってくださいと言える
でも 自分で意見を持たない人は
野球はうまくいけば幸福であって
うまくいかなかったらそこはものすごい地獄であってと分かりますでしょうに
相撲もそうでしょうに
相撲はうまくうまくいけば
横綱でもなればそれはすごいもんですよ
すごいお金儲かりますから
でも失敗しちゃったら体も壊して早く死んじゃうでしょうね
もう食べて食べてね まあ頑張って頑張ってでっかい体を作って
そこでうまくいかなかったと
途中でやめなくちゃいけないでしょ
そうすると あのでっかい体を持ってどうするんですかと
かわいそうでしょうに
だから仏教の立場から見れば
これこそっていうもの
何一つ言えなく 言えなく言えなく言えなくなるんです
うまくいけばいいんですけど
で うまくいったっても
そこにまたいろんなトラブルがまたあるんです
政治家もそうであるし
音楽家もそうであるし
いい音楽できればいいであって
売れれば大変幸福であって
売れなかったら大変もう地獄になってしまっちゃうし
1曲2曲だけ売れたんだところで抜群に
それからもうなかなか発想がなくなっちゃったらどうするんですかと
ですから そういうふうに物事は冷静な心で見て
自分が何にも入り込んでない
自分も生きるためには仕事を通して何かを選んで仕事はする
するんだけど これこそ人生だと思わないことと
そういうふうに何ものにもとらわれない
主婦であるならば 主婦の仕事はもうやる
それは仕事だからと だからといっていろいろ文句言ったり
なんで私はこればっかりやらなくちゃいけないんですかとかね
そういう文句は消えてしまう
ものにとらわれない心こそ心の超越だと
それは中道から生まれてくる超越なんですね
中道というのは正見 正しく物事を見る
正思 正しく物事を考える
正語 正しく物事を正しい言葉を喋る
正業 正しい行為をする
次に正命と書いてもう正しい仕事を選ぶと
で いくつ言ったっけ 精進ですね
そこで心を清らかに来ることに努力する
自分が頑張るのは もう金儲けようと頑張るんじゃなくて
心を清らかにしようと精進する
それで心の安らぎを確定
確定する 正定 あ 正念 それ書いて
そこで正念という 念というのは
この ありのまま物事を観察することで
物事をありのまま観察する
そこで心の統一 心の安らぎを確定する
症状と そういう八正道なんですね
それは道である 実践し始めたら結構面白いんです
やたらに喋るんじゃない
喋る時も言葉に気をつける
やたらになんだかんだみんなやるんだからやるんじゃなくて
自分がすることは まあこれでいいかなとちょっと気をつけてすると
なんだかんだむちゃくちゃなことを考えるんじゃなくて
まあこんなこと考えていいかなと思って
あまり余計なことを考えないで
明るく考える これ正思ですね
それで正見っていうのは何ですかというと
もういろんな変なところな意見は捨てちゃおう
私はそう信じてますから
そうですよとかね そういう意見は捨てて物事を見るとかね
そのような方法で我々の心は超越するだろうと思います
この超越という言葉 何で使いますかというと
人間でなくなっちゃいます
それ悪いことじゃないんです
人間の世界っていうのは苦しみそのものだから
みんな邪見 邪見じゃなくて我見持っていて
お互いに競争 戦いばっかりやってるんだから
嫌な気持ちしかもうもうたまりませんよ
気持ち心の中で 世の中の嫌なものばっかりなんですね
たとえどこかに行っちゃったら
何人銀行に行っても 10人ぐらいいるんだと
自分が早く自分の仕事したいでしょ
正直なところ これ10人がいると
12 11番目の自分が待たなくちゃいけないでしょ
それ 11番目で待ってますでしょ
並んで あれも嫌なんですよ
本当に言うと ああ 気持ちいいと待たされてというバカがいませんだから
だから生きるということはいつでもそんなもんで当たり前でやってますけど
毎日やってることは全て嫌なもんなんです
朝起きたところでお腹が空いてるんだと
お腹が空いてるのはいいで
ご飯食べるのは朝ご飯食べるのはいいんだけど
料理するのは嫌でしょ
本当は たとえトーストなんか焼いて
なんとかしてコーヒー飲めるようなヨーロッパ式な簡単なブレックファストにしたっても
なんかどこかで誰かやってくれるんだったらありがたいでしょ
ちゃんと 誰もやってくれなきゃ自分でやりますけど
結局はそんな微かなことさえ
心の本当のところから見るとやりたくないものなんです
何でも煩わしいんです
髪の毛洗うことも お風呂に入ることも
まあどうしようもないんだから
やってるだけで 歯磨くことも
だから歯をもう朝も晩も昼もいつでも磨いてるかもしれませんだけど
磨くたびにストレスが溜まる
お風呂に入るたびに 髪の毛洗うたび
ただ知らないだけで そういうすごい次元で見て
生は苦であるということをお釈迦様おっしゃってるんです
生は苦であるのは 生きることの中に我見があるんだからなんです
わがままということがあるんだからなんです
それでうまくいかない
だから自分を抑えちゃう
抑えることを我々は生きてることだと言うんです
子供にとっては箸でご飯食べるのはすごいきついんです
それは手で取って もうもうそのまま食べた方が楽なんですけど
やっぱりそれでうまくいかないということで
みんな箸の箸を訓練させちゃう
それは嫌なんですけど
全てそうなるものなんです
嫌でないものは一つもないんです
そこで嫌なものをあまり積み重ねるんだから
我々は娯楽という世界を作っちゃうんです
なんで娯楽に行きますかというと
あまりも嫌なものは積み重ねるんだからなんですね
もし人生は嫌でなければ
朝起きてご飯食べて 会社に行って
仕事をして夜帰ると それは嫌じゃないんだと
なんで酒飲みに行くんですかね？なんでたまに休みを取っていろんな遊びに行くんですかね
ですから ああいうのは偽善的な言い方で
やっぱり嫌なんです 何でもやるとストレスが溜まるんです
そこで娯楽も同じで嫌なものばっかりなんです
そこに行っちゃったら
自分好きな時は見せてくれないし
その場所に行かなくちゃいけないし
そちらは演奏家の勝手であるし
なんか自分やらされるっぱなしで
それは自分の自由は失っちゃうし
そこでまたストレス溜まっちゃう
だから毎日は行かない
娯楽にもほどほどにしている
毎日に毎日行ったらあれは地獄だよと
頭おかしい人々だけ追っかけやってますけどね
それは病気ですからね
それはもう完全な病気なんですね
すごい影響を受けて あまりにも精神的に弱くて
そんなもんなんですね
世界って 全てこれいいという
本当に厳密に見るとかすかに一つもない
そこで心調和するためには
だからこれ何で嫌ですかね
何でご飯作るのが嫌ですかね？何で掃除機かけるのは嫌ですかね
なんか自我意識がありまして
私という概念があって
なんかわがままでいたいんですね
そこはあるんだからなんです
ただそれだけ 自我さえ捨てれば何のこともないんです
例えば皆様にちょっと例を言います
もしこのビルの管理掃除しているおばあさんかおじさんがこっち来て
こちらの誰かに誰かにすいませんけど
あなた終わったら掃除機かけてくださいと言ったら
心はどんな反応します？ちょっと想像してみてください
まあこのビルだからビルの掃除する会社がいて
その会社の方々はもうちゃんとやってるんです
それ決まりで そこでそのおばさんが来て
こちらのどなたかに掃除機を任せて
あんたこれちゃんとやって机を拭いて
これでこれでちゃんと道具はそこに置いといてくださいと言ったらどうなるんですか？言われたら
想像できない結果になるでしょ
自分でもそんなこと言われませんから
皆様に想像できないかもしれませんだけど
言われたらそこにすごい喧嘩になる
あのおばさんがクビになっちゃう
こちら会社に電話してこんなこと言われたんだと
いわゆる自分があのおばさんが殺すということなんですね
わかりやすくで言えば
クビにするということはそういうことだから
確実にそれすると思いますよ
あんたどんな会社の人ですか？と名前なんですか？と
喧嘩できない場合はちゃんとその会社に電話して
こんな失礼なこと言われて
何ですかと あなたの会社はと言われたら
その会社はあのおばちゃんに任せたから
あなたはもう来なくていいと
だからそう言われたら
こちらの方々はどんな立派な方であろうとも僕は言いますよ
そんなのあなた方のこの文化的な立派さは全く無関心にあの人を殺すんです
それはなぜそうなるかというと
自我があるんだからなんです
何のこともないんです
なぜ私にこんなことを言うんですか？私という自我がなければ
ああそう これ掃除するの？はい
わかりましたと掃除するんです
何のこともなく それ苦しみもないんです
やりたくないという気持ちはかすかにもないんだから
私がここにいないんだから
そこでものすごい不思議な世界が生まれてくるんです
心調和の世界 すごい不思議なんです
皆様はそうじゃないんです
人間がそうじゃないんです
皆様も試しに会社に行ったところで
会社の社長でもいいし
部長でもいいし 自分がタバコを口につけて
あの課長 ちょっと火をつけてくださいと言ってみてください
どうなるんですかと なんでそんなことで喧嘩になるんですか？何のこともないでしょうに
はい 分かりましたとライターで火をつけちゃければいいのに
考えてみてください あそこは何が問題ですかね？何が悪いですかね？誰が悪いことしたんですか？自分にライターがなければ
タバコも吸いたい場合は
課長ライターが持ってるならば当たり前の話でしょうに
でもそうじゃないでしょう
あれは自我なんです なんで子供は母に対して怒るんですか？自我なんです
なんで母は子供に子供に怒るんですか？自我なんです
そこで苦しみが生まれてくる
喧嘩が生まれてくる そこで競争の世界が生まれてくる
こんなやり方で いくら世界が変化したっても
苦しみは終わりがない
我々は神に作られた尊い人間だよと
人生っていうのは尊いものだよというトンデモない嘘を言っちゃうと
永遠に人間の苦しみが終わりない
だから輪廻という概念が出てくるんです
苦しみの回転だと 仏教は堂々と言う
尊い命 いや 苦しみのみの
何でもない そういう風にちょうど高いレベルで
今日はちょっと ちょっと次元が僕はほんのかすかに上げて喋ってるんです
チョイスだから ほんのかすかなのでもっと上げられますよ
ですからこの そういうふうに見てください
自我があって 自我が 自我意識があって
それによって何だかんでも我々は苦しみに回っている
だから全ては苦しみであると
それで仏教でこういうふうに実践するんです
ただ どこかで座って お茶一杯でも飲んで
気持ちよく座って 自分の人生を観察してみてください
生まれた時から今まで何をやってきたんですか？それは本当に楽しくやってきたんですか？今私が言った角度でとにかく自我を発見してください
なんで母と喧嘩した？喧嘩したんですか？学校に行ったことは本当に厳密に楽しかったかとか
朝早起きすることは楽しかったかとか
そう いつでも自分でやりたいことがあって
それはやらせなかったという
ずっと人生はそういうものであるとわかるんです
本当は人生の答え こういうことなんです
人生は何ですか？やりたいということがあります
それはやらせない 反対のことをやらせる
それが人生なんです でしょ？よく考えると
ずっとそんなもんなんです
そこに何があるんですか？やりたいことやらせないと
苦しいんです だからお釈迦様は苦であると
その苦を発見する人はこの智慧ですぐわかるんです
なんで苦しいかと これはやりたいことをやらせてちょうだいと言って
やってもやらせてくれないでしょ
自分でもやりません やりたいことは
やりたいことやっちゃったら
その場で苦しみ味わっちゃうんです
また不思議なことで 人間は放っておいてみてください
やりたい放題やってくださいと
やりたい放題やらせちゃったら
その場でもっとひどい苦しみが生まれてくる
僕はそれを知ってるんだから
もう誰にもこの戒律とか規則とか言わない
いじめてるんです 人間を
教えた時でも やっぱりもう何のことなく生徒たちをいじめてるんです
どうぞと レポートだったら
あの まあそんなに書くのが嫌だったらどうぞ書かなくても結構ですよと
何のことなく言うんです
一応私は私の仕事はちゃんとやりますから
それでも大学ではみんなものすごく怖くなるんです
ものすごい気柄っぽいんですけど
向こうの大学生って ああ言われたら怖くなるというと
書かなくてもいいですよと
なぜか試験は向こうは厳しいんです
大学の試験は ただで合格させないんです
入学試験よりすごい厳しいんです
ですから 徹底的に試験に試験を受けて
ちゃんと点数を取らなかったらもうダメです
だから せっかく大学に卒業できなかったら
それほど恥がないんですね
ですから レポートを書いた方が自分の勉強になって
自分には試験はやりやすくなるということは
本人が理解しなきゃ 僕は言っちゃったら反乱する
もう逆らっちゃう あんた方はちゃんとレポート書いた方がもうよく勉強できますよと
その方が試験では役に立ちますよとは言わない
それは自分の意見を言うことだから
どうぞと僕の言ってる
この前も言ったと思いますけど
これは大学じゃなくて普通のお坊さんたちのお坊さんたちの学校でしたから
そこに最下の子どもたちを見て
若いちっちゃな子どもたちを見て
私が試験出しちゃって難しいんですね
やっぱりみんなもうちょっとどこかでカニングしようと思ってた
僕はちょっと分かった
この子とこの子とこの子とも勉強あまりしてないんだから
今度はカニングするだろうと
僕はどうしたんですかというと
みんなにじゃあこの試験が始まる前に
みんな自分のノートとテキストを持ってください
持ってきてくださいと
で みんな持ってこないんですね
本当は自分の引き出しの中に隠してるんで
それを出せないんですね
向こうの決まりはそれは他のところに置いといて
鉛筆と書く紙だけ持って教室に入りなさいと言ってるのは普通ですけど
こっち隠してるんですね
僕は何のことなく取りなさいと
で 見たい放題見て書きなさいと
それでカニングはしたい放題してくださいと言って
それで私そう言われると怖いでしょ
カニングしないできなくなっちゃうんですね
僕は部屋を出て行っちゃったんです
出ていて ちゃんと時間終わるまでいて
終わるというのはいつも10分ぐらいにして
また教室に戻ったんです
やりたい放題やれと それでちゃんとした教育なんです
それも誰にもストレスなしに
僕もあの子供たちを叱る必要もないし
カニングしたければカニングすればいいし
そうすると向こう側も悪いことしているという気持ちもなくできるし
そこで本人もよく書かれたという自信もあるし
いくらなんでも点数をつける場合は
いくら本を見たくても自分の能力次第だから
点数には変わりませんよ
結局は 下手な学生はテキスト見てコピーしてて点数はもらわないんだから
もう分かってるんだから
ただもうコピーしてるだけだから
ちょっと頭回転する子はそれを見ながらも何か自分の理解は書きますから
それだけのこと ですから
このまあ 何のためにそれを言うか分かりませんだけど
とにかくこの人間っていうのは
僕は言いたかったのは
この自分をやりたいことをやらせちゃうと
すぐそこにもっとより巨大な苦しみを感じる
タバコでも吸いたい放題吸わせちゃったら同じことでしょう
麻薬も吸いたい放題吸わせちゃったら同じことであるし
子供たちがこのティンナーやらね
まあライターのガスやら吸いたいでしょ
吸わせてみてください
ガスのボンベぐらい買ってあげて
じゃあこれは終わりまで吸ってくださいと
やらないよ そうだったらやるな
そんなことやるなというよりは
買ってあげた方が僕はいいと思いますよ
僕のやり方は買ってあげる
じゃああなたには吸うためにこれとこれとこれと
それでやめる それだけで吸わない
知ってますから こんなわがままでいっちゃったら
さらに 生き地獄に陥っちまっちゃいますよと
ですから 人生はもう逃げられない
わがままやっちゃったら強力な生き地獄
じゃあわがままを抑えちゃったらそれはまた生き地獄
だから道は超越するしかない
ですから 我々は人生はドッカであると
苦しみであると観察する
ありがたいありがたいと観察しない
それにこの  ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのはそういう方法なんですね
そこで重々とわかってしまうんです
瞬間瞬間もう虚しくて消えてしまうんだと
これいいこれいいという瞬間何もない
で ある時ではもうやっぱりもうただ存在するのは苦のみではないかと
なんで自分が苦しみもうこれからも苦しむでしょう
これからも苦しむましょうと
必死でそういう希望をしなくちゃいけないんですかと
まあ嫌だという諦めの心が生まれてくる
その瞬間ですっとこの大きな山火事が瞬間に消えたような感じで
心には涼しい感じが生まれてくるんです
それでずっとその人はもう落ち着くんです
何にももう苦しみがなく
戦うことなく 巨大な強烈な落ち着きで生きてる
超越されている もう人間は超えてるんです
こんなバカなふざけた人間ではもうありません
そういう人に仏教では聖者と言うんです
仙人だと そういうのもあまりこの
何と言いますか この観念的な言葉じゃないんです
仏教は科学だから 科学は科学じゃないんです
仏教こそ科学なんです
だからきちんと実践して
もう体験できる心の境地なんです
ですから 仏教でこの全てはドッカですよと
ドッカという言葉を覚えておいてください
ドッカ これは苦しみ苦という言葉に訳するんです
ドッカですよというのは
ただ単に一側面 世の中の一側面を見て
お釈迦様の偏見ではないんです
よく僕に質問されたことがあるんです
人生は苦しみでいたっても楽しみがあるんじゃないんですかと
僕はあまり答えない もう家族がいて
もういろいろ楽しみがいっぱいあるでしょうし
なんでお釈迦様は苦しみだけと言うんで
それはもう楽しみの中にあるいろいろいくらかの苦しみのことを言ってるんではないかと
僕は全然そういう人には答えません
怒るかごまかすか もうなんとかなんとか
なぜかというと わかるわけないでしょうに
これはすごい高いレベルで徹底的に全てはドッカだよと言ってるんだから
そこまでもう五 六時間かけて説法する必要ない人は質問したらすぐ答えなくちゃいけないんだから
[背景音楽]どう見たってももう逃げ道がない
それは仏教でさらに広げて言うんです
天界に生まれても たとえ超次元なところに生まれ変わっても
存在だから生きてるものだから
わがままだから やりたいことがあって
これやっちゃったらもうダメでやっていけないことをやらなくちゃいけない
やっていけないでは やりたくないことをやらなくちゃいけない
ですから どこに生まれても苦しみです
ドッカです たとえ天国に生まれても人間だけなんです
天国に行きたがるのは
なぜかというと 天国の話ありますでしょ
それは行って帰った人が書いたことかどうかはわかりませんだけど
よくこの一般の人々はよく天国の話を書くんです
お釈迦様なんかはほんのかすかにちょろちょろと言ってるだけで
まあそれもすごい科学的にも理解できますけどね
その上 この弥陀で書かれた仏教文献を見ると
まあ天国は何か行って帰って見たような感じで
地獄の話でもあんなものはどうか分かりませんだけど
とにかく天国に行けばなんだかんだも自分の希望通りにあるんだと音楽を奏でているわ
もう食べたい放題食べ物あるわ
女の人遊びたい放題いるわとかね
それこれはこの人間の立場から見る
まあ馬鹿げたな幸福論なんですね
天国はそんな甘い世界じゃないんで
天国も人間よりは自己次元であって
で 例えば体が我々みたいにきつい体がない
だから我々に見えないんです
素粒子みたいな体だから
素粒子みたいな体だから食べなくたっていいでしょ
素粒子でも別に維持するためには何か他のエネルギーを入れなくたってもいいんだから
その分は楽なんです でも心のエネルギーは強烈なんですね
ある天界があって これはお釈迦様の言葉で
その天界では大変なことになるんだと
自分たちが大変幸福で楽しく遊んでいるんだと
いわゆる楽を感じて生きているんだと
ああ 楽しいと なぜならば
天界に行っちゃったら
毎日ものすごく喜びで幸福で遊びにふけていないと死んじゃうんです
そういう次元なんです
我々は毎日苦しいんだから
ああ いいな 遊びにふけっていられるならばとかね
ずっと遊びだけで生きていられるならば
それほど幸福がないやと
天国天界は幸福の世界だと思ってるんですね
そこでおう 嘘を言ってるんだから
まあ極楽道なんかあるんだとかね
ないんですよ 楽に悟られる世界とかね
まあ怠けもいい程々にしろと言いたい
で その天界ではそういう風に必死で喜ばなくちゃいけないんです
結局我々の人生と同じなんです
我々は必死で仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
死ぬくらい思いで そうでなきゃ生きていられないんです
同じく天国に行っちゃったら
じゃあ必死で楽しめと
そうでなきゃ死ぬと 確実にする
お釈迦様ちゃんとそれを言っちゃってるんです
そこである天界ではこの一緒に楽しく遊んでいると自分と同じ他の神々もいるでしょ
生命はいっぱいいるんだから
そこでたまに自分よりレベル高く楽しんでる人々見えるんです
そうすると嫉妬するんです
あちらの方がいいんじゃないかなと羨ましがっちゃうんです
人間にもあること同じ現象なんですね
ピアノを弾ける人が威張ってピアノを弾いてると
もう一人の人が弾いてみたら
その人の方がすごい上手に楽々に弾いてるんじゃないかなと分かったら
なんとなく嫉妬が出て
たとえゴルフやったっても
もうバンカーにも入れないで
あの 何て言いますか 池みたいなものありますね
あっちにも落とさないで
ちゃんと打つ人を見ると何か羨ましくなっちゃうんですね
それたまたま 例えばバンカーからいきなりあの穴の中に落とす
落としちゃったならば
これ俺にもできればいいなと思っちゃうでしょ
ああいう風な感じが かすかにでも天界に生まれちゃったら
その場でそれで死んじゃう
なぜならば 嫉妬と幸福っていうのは違うエネルギーなんです
だからかわいそうなんですよ
天界にいたってちょっとでも嫉妬したらもう消えちゃう
はじけちゃう 人間はそんな嫉妬しただけで死にませんよ
なくなればすごいすごい体持ってるんだから
物質的に そこ地獄なんか行ったらまた次元違うんです
そこで生きるエネルギーっていうのは
怒り 苦しみも悩みなんですね
だから自分をいじめればいじめるほど
痛めれば痛めるほど その刺激で生きてるんです
それぐらい体のついてる物質とは違うんです
だから僕らに今三次元の世界ではちょっと想像できないだけ
もし地獄のいる生命が違うことを考えちゃったら
楽しみのこととか 嫉妬ではなく
その代わりに優しいことと考えたら
その瞬間で死ぬ 死んでいいところに生まれてくる
生まれて ですから 仏教の地獄は永遠じゃない
天国も永遠じゃない 自分持っていた
あの 何といいますか あのトラベラーズチェックですか
それは終わったらもう帰ると
持っていたお金がまあ終わったら帰らなくちゃいけない
で それからもう一つ展開がありまして
自分の意思の通りに喜べるという
自分が何か希望する 希望したものは出てくる
自分には現れる いわゆるまあ幻想みたいな世界だから
例えばあのビーチボールで遊びたいなと思ったら
まあそれは人間で例えるんだけど
神々はそうじゃないかもしれませんだけど
ビーチボールで遊びたいなと思ったら
ビーチボールがさっと出てくると
海岸あったらビーチボールで海岸だった方がいいなと思ったら
そこにその人に海岸が現れてくるような感じなんです
そういうふうに理解してください
思った通りに自分に楽しまれる
とにかく楽しまなくちゃいけないんです
楽しむことを忘れちゃったら
もう命は終わりと そこだったら
毎日毎日新しい新しいことを思って
思って楽しめばいいでしょ
それまたできないんです
いろんなものを考えられないんです
そこである日 もう遊んで遊んで
また明日何を もう今日は何をして遊ぶかという
この想像力ですか できなくなっちゃうんです
いわゆる何かしたいという希望のエネルギーが消えちゃう
はい 終わり さよならと
それで死んじゃう すごい
この何て言いますか すごいもろいもんなんです
で 人間と天界に行きたがるのは
ただ単に一つの理由 寿命が長い
それだけ 仏教の人々も
まあ天界に行きたいなと思うと一生懸命功徳を積む人々はいるんです
それなぜかというと 寿命が長い
それだけ 寿命が長いのはこの心だけのエネルギーだから
心の欲っていうのはそんな簡単に消えませんでしょ
ですから まあ人間より寿命がない
我々は物質の DNA でもう死ねと言っちゃったら
まあ死ななくちゃいけない
心では死にたくない  DNA 壊れちゃったら死ななくちゃ
我々は物質のよりレベルが低いんですね
心の次元が 向こうは物質を乗り越えて
ちょっと次元が高い その次元はたくさんあります
ですから 仏教のそちらでも
やっぱり神々もなんとなく喧嘩なんかしたいだろうと僕は思いますよ
遊びばっかりで面白くないんだからね
毎日 それしなかった やらなかったら死ぬでしょうに
皆さん同じです 毎日仕事ばっかりやって楽しくないでしょうに
お母さんにしたっても
朝食事作って 昼食事作って
夜はまたまたそう おじ洗濯して
また弁当作ったり また次の朝また同じことしたりとかね
今日は朝早く起きたんだから
明日ぐらい朝寝坊したいという気持ちあるでしょうね
毎日そんなことをやりたくないでしょ
結局は でもやらなきゃダメだからやってるだけ
男性の方々もそうなんです
会社に行くやつは他のところに行けばいいのに
やっぱりそれは危ないしね
だから会社に行く 神もそうなんです
遊ばなくちゃいけないんだから遊んでるんであって
あれ仕事であって たまに喧嘩でもしてやらいいなと思うでしょうと思いますよ
だからそこにストレス溜まる
喧嘩しちゃったらすぐ死ぬんだし
この日本語の言葉でありますね
阿修羅という言葉が 仏教で
それは地獄に入れてるんですね
阿修羅っていうのは神の反対なんです
空は神で 阿修羅は非神なんですね
まあまあ それは私がおかしく作ってる言葉で
スラっていうのは神 いわゆる神々という意味で
阿修羅といえば否定形で
スラと書くんです 神の
で 阿修羅と書くんです
この阿修羅が日本語でなかなか訳できなくて阿修羅と
それは神という感じかけならば
ここにはもう非という争うという感じか
ではそんなことなんで
でもそういう感じはないんです
とにかく それどういうことかというと
空っていう方々はお互いに楽しむことで生命の質を作ってるんです
それは逆にお互いに戦うことで
相手に相手を戦うことで生きてるんです
だから毎日喧嘩しなくちゃいけないんです
二人で会ったらもう喧嘩する
それで二人だけでは面白くないんだから
20人でやりましょうと
それで 20年  20年でもうお互いに喧嘩する
それでもまあもうやりたい放題と
恐ろしく そうやめちゃったら死んでしまいそう
そういうふうな次元もあって
だからそれはもう仏教から見れば
見れば正真正銘の地獄なんですね
そこで人間の次元の不思議なことは
そういうのは全部ちょっとちょっとちょっとちょっとあるんです
喧嘩すること 自分の人生にしている人々いるでしょ
なんとかなったら喧嘩
なんとかあったら喧嘩する
人殺すことを自分の人生だと思っている人がいるでしょうね
遊ぶことは自分の目的だと思っている人々いるでしょう
全部揃ってるんです こちらに
だからある人々言うんです
地獄も天国もこの世の中にあるんだと
それも別に間違っているわけでもないんです
私たちは何に喜びを感じるかと
何を刺激にするんですかと
私は例えば怒ること 嫉妬が刺激にして生きているならば
私は地獄にいて みんなに優しくして
仲良くして 楽しくすることは
ニコニコすることは 自分の生きる刺激だなと思ったら
もう天国であって ですから
仏教の最終的な言葉って
どこに生まれ変わってもドッカですと
天国で楽しむことさえよく考える
ただのドッカですよ それにはですから解脱しましょうと
それにもう時間なんですけど
ちょっとした理由があるんです
いわゆる論理的な根拠があるんです
仏教は科学と言うんだからね
ちゃんとした論理的な土台がなければね
そういう話だけ進みませんから
どういうことかというと
全ての現象は常に変化しつつなんです
いつでも変化しているんです
これという現象がないんです
こんな瞬間で次の現象に変わっちゃうんです
一切自分の心を見てください
瞬間瞬間変化して変化して
今泣いてるんだけど すぐ笑ったりするし
今元気なのにすぐ眠くなったりしまったりするし
もう自分でも次にどういう変化するかわからないでしょうね
じゃあ皆様に聞いたらわかりますかね
次に旦那さんと喧嘩するのはいつですかと
そんなことわからないでしょうに
心の変化だから その時はもう喧嘩になっちゃうし
あるいは喧嘩しようと計画立てたところで喧嘩しない場合もあるし
心のことだからわからない
すぐ変化する すべては変化する
すべては変化する それが存在という
心は変化する 物質は変化する
素粒子は変化する 素粒子さえ
それそれを視さえずっと流れているんだから
たった一個の核を原子ですか
原子を取ってみたっても
原子としてえらいもうカッコたるものと思っちゃう
そうじゃないでしょうに
いろんなもうその中に入ったりするんだから
であの構成は変わったりするんだから
もうどちらがどちらかとも言えないんです
ですから このすべては徹底的な無常であると
心も物質ですから とらわれるものは何もない
それは無常を観察する
無常を理解する 無常だからこそ解脱は成り立つのです
そこで無常と我の関係は何ですかと
人間っていうのはこの
無常ですけど 何かこれは私だと何か掴まれたいんです
何か足場が欲しいんです
でもそんな足場がないんです
今私というこの体も この心も
ずっともう瞬間に変化してしまっちゃうんですね
全く量的質的違うものなんで
次にある 母が産んだくれた細胞はもう一つもここにないんです
母が育ててくれた心はもう全くまるっきりないんです
それでも私 私というふうなもう何か思っているだけ
その思っていることこそ苦しみの元であって
ですから そう思うのは全部無常だと
全部消えているものだ
これ消えて違うもの生まれと
それすぐ消えて違うものが生まれる
それ消えてすぐ違うものが生まれる
だから初めがないんだと
ある人神という人がもう天と地が作ったんだと
冗談じゃないんです その神がどこから来たんですかということがそこに堂々とあるんだから
それよりもこういうことが正しいんです
あの またこの神に作られたということは
この完全たる嘘でもないんです
それのいくらかの根拠はあるんです
どういう根拠かというと
この物質の今の地球 地球と宇宙というのは
この素粒子の変化によってどんどんどんどん変化して
エネルギーの変化によってこの形が崩れていっちゃうでしょうね
地球も太陽も全部崩れて崩れていて
どんどんこのデンシティ
この質量ですか それは強くなるか薄くなるか
どっちかにするんですね
質量がどんどんどんどん吸収していっちゃうと
あんまりにもありすぎて
もういられなくなって
ポンと爆発して 全部また何も何もない形のない
単なる素粒子の波だけのものになってしまっちゃうんです
そこで何も形がない ではまたどんどん素粒子は 1個
2個  1個ずつまたつなげたりして
またどんどん原子ができたり
またどんどん また宇宙が現れたりしたりする
だから前何かあって 次に何かが生まれるという現象です
そういうふうなもので
何もない状態から いわゆる真空状態から
じわじわと徐々に徐々にこの実際の世界が生まれてくると
そこに徐々にこういう形の体が出てきたりはある
そこにずっとまた心という波動も発している
ということで そこら辺
なんか偏見で見ると まあある日突然神が作ったということは言えます
そこに神というのは心であって
仏教から見れば いわゆる心は全ての生命の心は一つに行動する
一体になって そこで最初の物質が現れてきて
それでまた心がバラバラになっちゃって
まあ元のバラバラ状態になっちゃって
生命は別々になるんだと
もともと生命は別個 たまに別々で行動する
たまに一緒に行動する
人間と同じなんです たまに家族で行動する
たまに別々に行動する
それはどんな次元で見たっても同じこと
宇宙の次元で見たって
ある時は心は別々に 今は現象の次元だから別々に行動していて
地球は破壊するとまとめちゃう
もう別々にはもういられないんだと
それだけ そのまとめることは
ヒンドゥー教で梵我一如の状態だと言ってるだけ
僕ら仏教での梵我一如にまた戻りますよ
まあ安心するなと 梵我一如状態は否定してないんです
この瞑想すれば その悟りを得られれば
やっぱりその梵天に生まれ変われます
そこであんまり区別はない
波動がつなげて あの 何て言いますか
オーバーラッピング お互いに積み重なっているんですね
心の波動 それは一体だと感じるだけ
まあそれはまあちょっとあんまりレベルももうわからなくなりますからね
まあそこは余計な話やめましょう
まあちょっとなんか現実から離れるようになりますからね
まあ宇宙論喋っちゃうと
で そういうことで 我々はヴィパッサナーという簡単な方法で
全てのものは無常であると
そこに自我がないんだと体験することで心は超越するんだと
方法は簡単です こちらは講義だから
実践の方にはもう触れようとしない
まあ時間 もし機会があったならば実践して
この素晴らしいことを体験してみてください
ありがとうございました